so is it fair to say just like this idea
that the laws of mathematics are
discovered
they're Laden within the fabric of the
universe in that same way the laws of
biology are kind of discovered yeah I
think that's absolutely and it's
probably not a popular view but I think
that's right on the money yeah well I
think that's a really deep idea
then embryogenesis is the process of
revealing of
um
embodying of manifesting these laws
you're not building the laws you're just
creating the capacity to reveal yes I
think again not the standard view of
molecular biology by any means but I
think that's right on the money I'll
give you a simple example you know some
of our latest work with these xenobots
right so what we've done is to take some
skin cells off of an early frog embryo
and basically ask about their plasticity
if we give you a chance to sort of
reboot your multicellularity in a
different context what would you do
because what you might assume by the
thing about embryogenesis is that it's
super reliable right it's very robust
and that really obscures some of its
most interesting features we get used to
it we get used to the fact that acorns
make oak trees and frog eggs make frogs
and we say well what else is going to
make that's what it you know that's what
it makes that's a standard story
but the reality is and so and so you
look at these um these skin cells you
say well what do they know how to do
well they know how to be a passive
boring two-dimensional outer layer
keeping the bacteria from getting into
the embryo that's what they know how to
do well it turns out that if you take
these skin cells and you remove the rest
of the embryo so you remove all of the
rest of the cells and you say well
you're by yourself now what do you want
to do so what they do is they form this
little um this multi-little creature
that runs around the dish they have all
kinds of incredible capacities they
navigate through mazes they have various
behaviors that they do both
independently and and together they uh
they have a uh but they basically they
Implement Von Neumann's dream of
self-replication because if you sprinkle
a bunch of loose cells into the dish
what they do is they run around they
collect those cells into little piles
they they sort of mush them together
until those little piles become the next
generation of xenobots so you've got
this machine that builds copies of
itself from loose material in its
environment none of this are
things that you would have expected from
the Frog genome in fact there's wild
type the genome was wild type there's
nothing wrong with their genetics
nothing has been added no Nano materials
no genomic editing nothing and so what
we have done there is engineer by
subtraction which you've done is you've
removed the other cells that normally
basically bully these cells into being
skin cells and you find out that what
they really want to do is is uh to be
this they want their default behaviors
to be a xenobot but in Vivo in the
embryo they get told to be skinned by
these other cell types and so so now so
now here comes this this really
interesting question that you just posed
when you ask where does the form of the
tadpole and the Frog come from the
standard answer as well it's it's it's a
selection so over over millions of years
right it's been shaped to to produce the
specific body with that's fit for froggy
environments where does the shape of the
xenobot come from there's never been any
zenobots there's never been selection to
be a good xenobi these cells find
themselves in the new environment in 48
hours they figure out how to be an
entirely different uh proto-organism
with new capacities like kinematic
self-replication that's not how frogs or
tadpoles replicate we've made it
impossible for them to replicate their
normal way within a couple days these
guys find a new way of doing it that's
not done anywhere else in the biosphere